science fiction often warns us about the
dangers of tinkering with time super
time force couldn't care less the game
assumes a hilariously cavalier attitude
about the rights and wrongs of fiddling
with history sending up every sci-fi
time-travel trope in the book the moment
doctor repeats key cracks the conundrum
of time travel late 1980s America
becomes a hellscape overrun by angry
robots but rather than undoing his work
and setting time right again
repeats key and his super time force
harnessed the power of time travel in
pursuit of the most frivolous goals
imaginable one mission has you venturing
to the year 673 to steal the Holy Grail
just to save a chain of medieval themed
restaurants another has the team
venturing into the 31st century
so that repeats he can get all the
browser updates and plugins he needs to
watch funny cat videos there's a twisted
glee and hopping through time not in the
name of Justice or saving humanity but
just to serve the whims of one man
your missions in super time force play
out like stages from run-and-gun
shooters but the members of the force
have one trick up their sleeves that
bill and lance of contra could only
dream up at any time you can stop the
action and rewind it
then spawn into the level as another
character or as another copy of the same
character you were already controlling
this doesn't erase what you did
previously
instead you fight alongside yourself
manipulating time to adapt to the
challenges you encounter in a stage is
usually an enjoyable process you might
use the heavy artillery of genre moi to
advance get killed by an enemy explosive
then rewind the action and switch to
sharpshooter ami McQuillen whose charge
shot can pass through objects using her
to eliminate the enemy before he even
has a chance to toss the explosive in
the first place preventing Rambo from
dying when you save a character like
this you can collect his or her essence
giving your current character another
point of health and the offensive
capabilities of the character you
rescued the action has the frantic shoot
anything that moves fun common good
side-scrolling shooters and the level
design is inventive and entertaining
throughout tossing you into an ancient
theme park a road warrior ask
post-apocalypse and the brains of a
computer filled with awful websites from
the Geocities era the abilities of the
members of the super time forests are
varied and complement each other nicely
the aptly named shield II blocker Sam
can protect his teammates for instance
and zakah Soros Wells echo Soros is a
skateboarding dinosaur which is just
cool
but it's the time manipulation mechanic
that sets super time force apart not
entirely unlike the joy of teaming up
with friends to overwhelm enemies in a
multiplayer game there's a strange sense
of camaraderie and cooperation with
yourself in super time force as you see
one character you from a minute ago
gunning down one enemy while you take
control of another character to
eliminate another foe but not every
scenario is so enjoyable particularly
during boss fights the game realized too
heavily on the time manipulation
mechanic time is short so you need to
whittle down the health of bosses as
quickly as possible so you rewind the
action and layer more members of the
super time force into the landscape
until there are enough of them firing
enough bullets at the boss to defeat it
before time runs out in these situations
you might spend more time rewinding the
action than experiencing it and placing
more and more characters into the
environment becomes not so much a matter
of intelligently adapting to the
challenges before you but if employing
sheer brute force
your victories don't require much
thought or skill so they aren't
rewarding but that's a minor gripe with
a really funny game that puts an
innovative twist on the side-scrolling
shooter in his classic story a sound of
thunder
Ray Bradbury warned us that even killing
a butterfly that lived millions of years
ago might have devastating effects on
the present super time force responds to
such concerns with a gleeful who cares
toying with time is too much fun to
worry about the consequences
you